and welcome to AI plus a R equals
superpowers and this is not a
mathematical equation augmented reality
and artificial intelligence and
superpowers that's what we're going to
talk about so what is what are these
what are these terms
AI you don't have to think about AI you
don't have to think about when talking
about it I don't have to think about
stuff like terminators who are going to
kill all humanity or even Siri or Google
assistant or anybody else strictly
defined AI is is when machines are
displaying signs of intelligence or
demonstrating intelligence so I'm sure
as many of you have created a small game
in when I have to think about the number
between 1 and 10 and the computer asks
me is it larger than five and then I
asked well yes and you and slowly the
computer will guess the number that I
have thought of and that's AI it's just
a simple set of ifs but it's artificial
its intelligence of course the more
exciting part of AI is is part of this
it's called machine learning and machine
learning is when we're not explicitly
programming every single decision into
the system but we allow it to learn we
give it data to learn from and we have
some kind of way of verifying that the
current state of the learning how where
it is basically we created the machine
or rather it grace himself and then fine
Tunes those little tweaks inside his
head or its head and the most
interesting and and really revolutionary
part of machine learning is of course
deep learning deep learning is when you
have hundreds and hundreds of layers and
each layer can have thousands or tens of
thousands of these neurons which have a
tiny bit of resemblance to the
biological neuron
and they are connected together so the
artificial neurons just implement a very
simple mathematical function some
additions multiplications but they are
wired together in a way that as the end
result you get something that we
couldn't do a couple of decades ago or
even a decade ago something like speech
recognition which we now use all the
time on our phones or image recognition
I show it a picture of an apple and it
tells me that it's an apple but of
course it has no idea what an apple is
it just knows that the APPL AE character
sequence belongs to this picture so
that's that's well that's what I mean
that I'm talking about AI now let's talk
about augmented reality augmented
reality my favorite definition is it's
an interactive real-time special effects
or CGI like what you see in a movie so
here is this handsome fellow and you can
see that this is a real-time application
on iOS and my body has been redrawn with
bit basically something that looks like
a pencil sketch so this is AR and of
course this is a are when there's
obviously not a single stormtrooper on
this field but still through the phone's
camera you can see that and these these
stormtroopers are like they were in the
actual scene of course we can use AR for
much more useful stuff such as
navigation this is Google's AR
navigation walking directions you have
these huge arrows sticking out from not
even from the ground that they're
levitating and they show you where to
turn so you know you don't get lost or
you can use AR to do stuff like
measuring this is on awesome superpower
of just looking at something and knowing
how big it is
and all you need is a thousand-dollar
phone instead of a $2 measuring tape
that's also not as precise but you know
whatever this is AR and of course this
is AR as well and this is the most
popular form of AR when I have the
superpower of changing myself into
somebody else or some other something
and this is actually a very lucrative
form of we are within with Instagram and
snapchat filters they're actually making
serious money through advertising
advertisement using these but the kind
of way I a are I'm most excited about is
when you're having an AR headset and how
many of you have experience in AR had
said before okay so that's about half
the people here
er heads that are very different from
this mobile AR that I just showed you
because they have this transparent glass
which projects light into your eyes so
you can see the real world just like I
can see you now except for all of those
lights and you can see the artificially
generated images and because we have two
eyes and it has two image generators or
image projectors and it also knows how I
move in three-dimensional space that
means that it can calculate that as I
move from that point of view for example
if I wanted to have a virtual ways on
this table it could calculate what
pixels it has to project into both of my
eyes so that I can have a virtual ways
and the illusion is pretty good it's far
from perfect now I'm not saying that but
it's pretty good so I have the ability
to magically conquer conquer not conquer
I don't know anyway magically make it
appear that there is a ways here and
anybody who's wearing that glass is will
have some kind of belief on that so
that's that's what I'm most excited
about and when talking about superpowers
I'm not gonna give you the superpower of
lifting cars I'm sorry yeah Anna Anna or
you know the super power of flight
which is also something that I can't do
with AI and AR and I also can't give you
the superpower the ultimate super
powerful billions and billions of
dollars but I do I can give you the
superpower of magic and it's not just
magic it's actually gonna be useful
magic and because this is not a magic
show I asked I'm gonna s play explain
how some of these magic tricks that I'm
gonna show you are actually created so
that hopefully I can I can give you
something so let's see what kind of
magic we are talking about here is an
example number one I'm wearing a magic
clip in this by the way you can see that
I could just conjure up a cube like that
and you know that it's a real cube
because it lights up my hand well okay
it's a it's a pulsating cube light and I
can bring up another one and then I have
a red red cube and a blue cube and they
look pretty real to me
I mean I know they are not real but they
are they're in three dimensions when I'm
wearing this glass and I can just move
my hand around them and you know make
them disappear when I had enough so this
is cool right but it the similar
technique can be used to do something a
little bit more useful like conjuring up
an iPhone and this iPhone weighs zero
grams
I bet the Tim Cook won't be able to
reach that soon and it can levitate and
it stays in place and I can actually
grab my finger and press some of the
buttons so and then make it disappear
when I don't I no longer need it so how
do you think I did this
nobody
okay so that would sort of way I did
this is that I had a 3d model of an
iPhone of course and magiclip has hand
recognition and adjust your recognition
so basically when I it recognizes an
open palm it will put the iPhone model
over there when the tracking has a
closed form it will make the iPhone
model disappear pretty easy and as for
pressing the button I recorded a small
video on an iPhone of me pressing the
weather applications button and when
when I did this with one of my hands I
press the button on a controller on the
other one so that that start is playing
the video it's not so magical after I
explain it but I think it's it's
interesting this is another favorite
magic trick of mine this is this I call
hand throwing but you may have seen
something similar in Star Wars movies so
what's gonna happen is here's my hand
and I'm going to concentrate and there
is another hand of mine and I can
actually manipulate physical objects
with it so how was this world how was
this created yeah with you know a close
this was created with the help of my
lovely wife so this is the Weirich film
and we should have some audio maybe it's
my problem anyway so yeah that that's
how I was created I can't I'll count it
one two three and then she did the
physical stuff so that's fun going on
the same hand throwing technique can
actually be used to operate switches in
your smart home so like this I said like
this play button
here we go I perform the same throwing
gesture some reason it's very slow now
and then it turns on the light should be
much faster I'm sorry
that's PowerPoint and then I do it again
and it doesn't work and then I do it
again and it doesn't work and then also
try finally it works again so then I can
switch it off
so why didn't work I didn't create a
commercially adaptable gesture
recognition system all I did was I
created a small application that tracked
the speed of my hand and I said when the
speed the research reaches a certain
threshold and then it stops that's when
the gesture is triggered now this is
very error-prone this is fine for a
video but in real life when you're doing
stuff like this it had tons of false
positives and false negatives and in
everything like that so in real life
what I would do is invoke and next to a
R I would invoke AI and I would turn a
small neuron that works on hundreds and
hundreds of these samples from different
people and then it would probably be
much more reliable speaking of this
experiment I can't just count let it go
but why do we need switches anymore if
we have this we have this power of of
just throwing the hand now we can just
step the actual light instead of the
switch so that's like the difference
between using a mouse to click a button
versus pressing a button on a
touchscreen
okay enough of that there is so all of
this is fun but what I really am
enthusiastic about when it comes to air
and this kind of hats at a ours is when
we're not just augmenting reality we're
also augmenting humans
we're also menteng ourselves
our brains our cognitive functions and
this is a great example of that she's in
an industry she's in a factory and she's
learning how to put together an engine
and she has written text floating in
front of her so the both of her hands
are free and she also has these lies
handy arrows that point to where she has
to put that fuel regulator or whatever
and that saves a lot of time and
learning in the industry like this or
with VR with similar techniques has an
extremely high return of investment like
hundreds and hundreds of percents a very
high retention rate and an accelerated
learning which is which is very
important today this is a project that
we're working on at the company called
Aaron X and the idea here again is to
augment people to augment the condition
so we are working we are helping
aircraft engineers to analyze and and
the catalog aircraft effects I don't
know about you but I really would like
to fly home safe and one of the one of
the ways I can be fairly sure that that
will happen is because the what happens
is that the airplanes are routinely
inspected every square centimeter is
respected in every single dent or
lightning strike or whatnot is
categorized and analyzed whether they
are safe for flight or whether they have
to be fixed first every single dent and
this is a very manual process and this
is also a process that requires a lot of
paperwork a lot of human writing and
reading and there's an 18,000 page
manual for every aircraft that you have
to be up-to-date on to decide whether Oh
a damage is something that you can allow
the plane to fly so what we're doing and
what he's seeing when he is he's putting
on his headset is this great on the
airplane and the existing damages well
however small and then he can select the
damage and he has every data for that
damage right next to him and we have a
60 40 to 60 meter plane and we can
position these damages with a few
millimeters of precision which is pretty
cool and this is required so that you
can make the decision another favorite
puzzle of mine is the Rubik's Cube how
many of you can know what a Rubik's Cube
is that's pretty much everybody how many
of you can solve the Rubik's Cube yeah
that's usually about five percent of the
population and how many of you know how
to solve the rubik's cube because you
figured out yourself without any
external help
yeah that's awesome
they say that there's about 500 people
like you who can just figure out figure
it out but anyway I couldn't I can't and
a lot of us can't
but Rubik's Cube is and it's such a hard
puzzle because it has something like 43
quintillion different states and only
one of those are considered to be solved
and you know that 43 quintillion is a
pretty big number because different
combinations has a lot of leather and
that's still wider than that
so I'm fascinated by how AR can help
solve these challenges and another
similarly difficult problem is setting
the time on the microwave which happens
twice a year you know they're light
savings and all that and it's almost the
same difficulty because I have how would
you set the time on this one just with
these controls
the way you said it is you set the
strength to vertical and then with this
thing you rotated counterclockwise if
the door is closed 360 and then it it
gets into time setting mode and I know
this because I've done it a lot of times
but the first five years twice every
year I had to bring out the manual so so
what if I could just put on us put on a
smart glasses and I will see the same
our arrows in a somewhat better
representation but the same same kind of
idea oh that's how you said it or or
with your alarm system or or what not
similar like the Rubik's Cube so I
figured that if I could solve this
Rubik's Cube problem of mine then I
would be able to to give a good example
and my idea was to have have this
rubik's cube and for example if we need
to turn it that way then I would have a
three dimensional arrow rotating that
way that's the idea so I got to got to
work and this was last year I knew
absolutely nothing about computer vision
and your own networks you can testify
that I used to call these technologies
black magic but yeah III wanted to solve
this so I started to learn and this is
where I got last summer so this is a
cold object detection and the computer
vision can detect the cube even in a
scramble state as you can see and and
draw a little rectangle around it so I
figured that would be the first step so
how did I how did I get here well I
watched a couple of videos go to general
understanding but this book is the one
that actually puts me over the edge and
this book is the one that helped me
really understand how machine learning
and deep neural networks and computer
vision worked
so it told me that there this when the
computer says that this is a mouse
that's called objects or image
classification when the computer says
that this is a keyboard and this is a
mouse and roses little rectangles around
them that's object detection so now I at
least had a terminology to search for
and I knew that object detection would
only work if I had a varying set of
images so I went on to Bing and
downloaded 700 images with the word
beautiful because I figured that I would
look at these images a lot so at least
there should be aesthetically pleasing
and I downloaded all of these images as
you can see in I got stuff like I don't
know a beautiful glass butterfly or a
beautiful person or a beautiful
landscape all of these so then I went to
unity and I created this has disappeared
I created an application that would
allow me to randomly place and rotate a
rubik's cube so this would be my test
data the input data for the neural
network and I got this lovely cube from
cube model 3d model from a friend of
mine and I created a couple of scripts a
script that's a cube randomizer that was
rotated randomly and move it and scale
it randomly a screen recorder which put
output basically screenshots of every
such random random thing in the label
generator which outputs labels so I got
to start this application and I slowed
it down for you a little bit because if
anybody has epileptic seizures I don't
want you two to get it right now because
it was really fast
you can see on the left the layout of
this of the scene and you can see on the
right this is the image that has been
has been generated
5,000 of these why not I had no idea
what was the right number if it's 50
maybe it's more I don't know five
thousand sounded like a good idea
so on the left you can see the test
images generated on the right you can
see the data so for every single image
there is one row and there's this four
numbers sorry these four numbers which
contained the XYZ with and so on
coordinates of the bounding rectangle
and then I went to work I've wrote some
Python I wrote some I used some code
from the previously-mentioned book and I
started to train this neural network and
there's something called meta parameters
which are basically parameters that
control how the training works and
that's an art form that I didn't have
yet so after about 20-30 tries I managed
to get to the pole get to this stage
that you saw over for but what's
interesting about this is I have never
thought the neural network how to see
how to identify a scrambled cube all of
my examples were solved cubes and still
it managed to do this so I have no idea
why it can work with a scrambled cube my
guess is that it's it's probably gotten
to learn about these dark grids but
that's just my guess and I just learned
from Fiona before in an earlier talk
that they are raised to to track this
down but still a lot of people in the
industry have no idea how the neural
networks work and that's a whole
research area so that's that can be
pretty pretty dangerous where where AI
is used for stuff like deciding how long
a prison sentence should be that's again
an example that you wrote up but I had
it first
and how long a prison sentence should be
based on based on how likely this person
is to commit the crime again and then it
turned out that the system
was racially biased so people's lives
were decided by the system that's pretty
scary isn't it
okay so back to the Rubik's Cube last
year I show this video we don't have
sound anyway so as you can see basically
I managed to do what I set out I'm
solving the Rubik's Cube solely based on
the suggestions of my hololens which is
an augmented reality glass I have the
glasses on I have the Rubik's Cube in
front of me and I see the arrows and I'm
rotating them and it's awesome
now you can see that it's real because I
have a lot of debugging full right there
on this thing so I was really happy with
this but again this is a this is a
session where I'm not showing your magic
tricks I'm telling you how I did this so
anybody has any idea hi did this not you
you know it nobody so do this was the
key this this frame from the video I was
using a special cube that had blue tears
in it and every time I turn the cube it
sends a little Bluetooth message to my
hololens so that I know that the cube
has been turned and I can calculate the
next step so that's how I did it now I
know that there are some extremely
talented computer vision ists who can do
this with a with any special cube I'm
not one of them and I was perfectly
happy to get to here so again I managed
to solve a so a problem which is almost
as difficult as setting the timer sorry
the time on a microwave using augmented
reality and a little bit of fire escape
this have you seen this movie this is a
short movie called
sight it's seven years old nobody you
have awesome this this short movie is is
taking us to a future where everybody
has augmented reality contact lenses and
these augmented reality contact lenses
have full spatial awareness they know
they're Parekh where you are they know
what you're looking at and everything
else and I'm not gonna spoil it you
gotta watch it but there's one scene in
it when the protagonist goes on a date
and this is what he sees he sees how
likely this girl how much she likes him
he sees stuff like hobbies
stuffs he see stuff like his social
vowel-like future Twitter feed or
something and I thought about well this
would be very useful for me not for
dating but for everyday social
interactions just yesterday we had a
speakers dinner but before that I met
with another speaker and we went for
lunch and then we had the speaker's
dinner a few hours later and the guy I
spent two hours in my Dame with I
introduced myself again
because my face memory is just so
freakin horrible I had no idea in that
social situation that it was the same
guy I just spent lunch with so imagine
that I would be able to just look at it
look at him and you know oh yeah you
were that guy so I set out to build this
and the application I wanted to build is
to have facial recognition for every
single person that I follow on Twitter
and to do that the first step you have
to apply for Twitter developer access
and it this was a surprisingly painless
thing and then I downloaded all of the
people I follow on Twitter
well not the people but you know a
little bit of that they talked with this
tool called link to Twitter and then I
got this this is a list of people I
follow on Twitter at least a few 30 of
them and from app for every person I got
something like their ID Twitter ID their
Twitter name and an URL that tells me
where their profile picture can be
downloaded from all of this is public
data so then I of course created another
application and I downloaded all of the
profile pictures of the of the 1200
people that I follow and you can see
that everybody has different kind of
pictures
so this guy has a perfectly normal
picture he also has a perfectly normal
picture but it's really not his and this
picture okay
some people have these cartoony pictures
and because I work on the work a lot and
follow a lot of people with AR we are
affiliations a couple of people even
heavier VR glasses on them so okay this
is what we're working with
one picture per person and then I
uploaded these pictures to edger
cognitive services and I'm not gonna
bore you with all the code I had to
decide where they go to go with the free
or paid tier but I figured that you guys
were worth it for me so yeah let's let's
go with the paid also I didn't want
things to just break down right here at
the demo and it cost me so far something
like three or four euros so you guys
have worked all of that and then I
uploaded all of the images before to
ensure cognitive services the
interesting the only interesting part is
is this when I actually uploaded an
additional user data so that would be
the twitter ID of the person so that i
had some connections between the two so
the upload went semi successfully i got
a lot of fails and these are for people
whose profile image is not really over
human or not something that the face api
can work with but i got a lot of
successes and and totally unrelated but
I think it's interesting there's about
fifty percent of people among those I
follow who have a decent profile picture
versus those who who don't have a face
so okay I got a chance to recognize
people at least fifty percent of the
people that I follow on social media
that's way better than what I do by
myself so that's good
and then I did the training I wrote a
little application or little routine
that would poll the server every time
every second so that I would know when
the training is done and then I ran this
and the training actually took 0.7
seconds so all of that was unnecessary
but then I read the read I read forward
and and it turns out that if you train a
million people that is still done in
about half an hour which is pretty
awesome both of those things million
people and the half hour thing so then I
created the app and the way the
application works is that I first run a
local face detection so just on the
computer a face detection is there any
face on a picture and the reason I did
this was that if I accidentally leave
the computer on and it's and it starts
sending the picture of my wall to the
cloud many times a second to see who is
there that's gonna cost me a lot so
first I do a local face detection and if
there is there's no faces we just don't
go on and then I have to send it to the
azure cloud and call another face
detection there you can't call the face
identification directly because I don't
know why but the for this second step
gets me back an ID which I feed back to
the search that the actual face
identification and if there is something
that I can actually show then I open up
a web browser and show the Twitter feed
of that person so this is how it works
in theory let's see how it works in
practice
it takes a little time to boot up there
we go okay and I'm going to show it a
couple of pictures so this is my friend
fellow MVP Jessica angstrom now you can
see this is how quick it was
high-confidence 0.91% this is the you
can see the picture there
does the that's her profile picture and
you can see the Twitter feed on the
right okay that was easy even I could
have done this so the next next MVP
friend of mine mr. John Paolo and okay
so the thing is that the phone is
reflecting Jessica's face that's what it
was catching up on oh the screen yeah
thank you
not the phone the screen you can't
prepare for everything thank you so yeah
look at look at this it is the same guy
obviously but the profile picture he
wears sunglasses his eyes are not even
visible and he partially occludes his
face with his fingers still 86 88
percent confidence so here's another guy
come up here because I got a picture of
you but it's much better life yeah this
is Dallas and there you go and you can
see again how different his profile
picture is from his from the from the
actual picture that as you say thank you
thank you
because this is very similar to what you
look like now what the profile picture
is now and here is this this last
picture this is of Alex kipman who is
the inventor of Halloran's now in the
profile picture he has a beard he is a
mustache he has a hololens in front of
his face and still we are talking about
67 69 percent probability and way less
than one second response time and all of
this from just one picture for every
single person
so that's freaking amazing and also
freaking scary right that's that's how
technology is today both amazing and
both scary and this is important because
we are ready at the point in in history
when we are making decisions that will
influence how this tech is going to go
forward we are we are affecting the
future in a way that no that's a layman
could do before so we have a great power
and to to create something that's
hopefully uplifting that's hopefully
something that people will but that that
will enrich people's lives and not the
other way around and we have a great
power to do that and as you know with
great power comes great responsibility
speaking of super powers now this is
what super spider-man's uncle said wrong
this is what this extolled actually
originated from the French Revolution
but whatever it's still valid so that's
that's what we have to do be be careful
of how we use these amazing technologies
I'm unremarked and I give people super
powers thank you
[Applause]